N DeSANTISICLY
HICAORSTATES WITTER.I DEOBLEMS
WHAT A Y
A ER
WHEN THEYTHEYE ANNOUNCING
R , WHICH ISTHISY OFFER
A .'
ANTICIPAD EOPLE  LISNGR TRYING
JOINQU ON
THIS.
AR TS.'S STILL DIFFICULT TSTEN
TO
IT CAR FULLYTED.
THTRA FEO.U HEARFLY EAKINGTHIS,
CRING.
S SOMETHG PEOUSLY TWITTENO G SM'
RS AND IDMOCKING IT ALREADY
TW THIS LINKNDING OUT A
IT FUND RAISE FOR
HIS CAMPAIGN
NOT OFF  A SMOOTSTART. GLITCHY I
THS CONCERN AND THIS IS WHAT WL
CAMPAIGN SO FAR IS
WHERE VICONTROLLED I
EPS TALKING ABOU
KNEW IT WOULD BE AAIGN LAUNCAND
ISSUES.T'S HAVING A LOT OF
I DON'T EVNK IT'S
HAPPENING.
>> IT'VERYWK SUPPO ABOUT20 MINUO
HASN'TEDET.
SARAH,OUIAALYST.
AREA.GIVE ALYSIS O
>> WN THAT AUDIOPA
THEER
667,000 PELE TRYING TO LISTE
TWITBI
WHEN EN D S BBC H NK
UP TO 3 MILLION OPLE BUT WTH DIS
TRNGO TH
PR THAT ENA ENCY EVENT
IN ANY KIND  TECOGONOCMEDIA, P
IT CE EEC
IT'SAMOUNT OF PEOP THAT OFTEN M.
THE PROBLEIS THAT HE TRYG  MESSA
BY T TRADITIONAL MEDIA
TRN LAUNINMP DOESN'T WORK YOU'A
WERE LOOKING FOR.
OR HOP
S NOT.
BUE TO
HON THIOUOM
PRETTY.
THE WITHOIN
THIS
COMPENOWS  PUTA SMOOTH
RUNN WHICH IA  A
CAMPAIGN, DOING THIS
FOD A HUGE AMOUN
OF'S HAPPENGSTEAD BOUT
ROS RUNNING ON
HOW HE'SUNAIGN LOOKS LIKE, PTO .
THS NEGATIVEATTENTION AND RIGHT
'S CONTINUE
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
BE UNDONBY ANYTHING SAID LATER
TRL .
FIRST IMPRESSIONS MATTER AOT
ITS.IN A REALL
IMPORTANT LESSONT
YOU KNOW DMER DUCKS IN A ROWNDOW
THT 600,000 PEOPLE
MAN.
WHENED A COUPLE OF
MINUTES AGO,S OU300,000.OT OF PE
G KICKED OE OF T GLITCHES.
ARE NOT HOW LONG    E NUMBERS.
IT SHOULD BEBLBIY
MIAMI.SICAN
WHAT ARE YOURNT
IS' NEXT
THAT TWITTER
SAYSP AS
S RUNNING FOR
A  GAK THE
NED.
AT THIS T, IT'S UP AND
RUNNING ANIT.IT BGORNMUSK ANDS
ITST IN AND BRINYOU MORE
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD EAESE DeSANT
TE THIS UP ATHDO IN THIS
'T
SMOOTHLY.
THS CEY A FAIRCRITT THINK IT'S A
LONG LASTINGBL FOR HCAMPAIEA UD.
T FOCUNG
MORE ON HIS ALRS.
WITH V
NN. INTE
I DON'T THINK THIS WILL BE THE
DeSANTIS PRENTMPAIGN  AAY THEY
DESIGNE       T.
THPRT STARD
HAS PUT A OF THEIRIDELY PRAISEDN
PRTY TO LAUN
CAN'E  REPUBLICAN Y VOTERSAKERY,
DECISION BASED ON A TENIL
YOU'RE OUCA
EXPERT.
WH
DOES THIS MEAN?>>OL I
THIS IS NOT A SCRIPTEDLOOVERNOR
THE  I
TOMORROW.NOT TODAY.MANYN VOTERS
WHO ARRY FOR A
TERNVEO DONALD TRUMP
THATTHIS RACE IS INDEED TORH MA
ING
HE HASHRNG CHILDREN.
'S 4YE
ABOUT HALF THE AGE OF THE
AND ST THE SAME AS TO MAKE
COUT THERE.
QUICKLY
USK
TWITSI
CALL PERHAPS AND
T DO THAT IN
E ,
GOINRE.O SORTF LIVEHA
DONORS HAVE PUBLICAN HAVE.THAT .
DONALD HAS HAD THE LUXURY
THAT IS GEERE NTS BEFORE
T ONE THINTH
MPE RELYON THAT'S DIPAIGNS IRG
OUTSOURCE MUF WO OMPAIGN.
SOE SOME
QUESTIONS  A THE COL
R DeSANTIS WILL HAVEE SUPPORTER
ANMIRERS B HE'S A
CANDATE THERE IS TSUPERPACK T T
AG OESIRING THOUSANDS OF PRLS.
WI OF, WILL SESTAGE FOR THE SUC
SO FROM W.SO H NOT HAVE  TIME TO
TO EE
YES,E EXPECE FLORIDA.
SIGNED A BUNCH OWS,
A WHOLE44 YEARS OLD.SO TIS GENEN
AND CHALLENGE FOR HIM.
>> I SUSPECT THE
CAMPAIGN, DeSANTIS HIMSELF, EYAO